did Qatar by fans did Russia threaten to
ban the World Cup in Qatar and will a
match at this world cup note last 90 but
100 minutes all these rumors are
actually circulating on the net about
the FIFA World Cup in Qatar and even
more but not everything is actually true
we have checked that for you but first a
few facts about the biggest sporting
event of the Year this is the first ever
World Cup to be held in the Middle East
and it's the first World Cup to be held
in Winter Qatar is the smallest host
country in the World Cup history and the
World Cup in Qatar is by far the most
expensive tournament ever but will the
tournament be played all the way to the
final social media users so doubt about
that after Russia was banned by FIFA for
attacking Ukraine President Vladimir
Putin reportedly threatened Russia will
play at the Qatar 2022 World Cup or
there will be no World Cup to talk about
as this via all Facebook post suggests
false
there's no proof that Putin said that
and no media has actually reported about
that even on the Kremlin website where
all Putin speeches are documented there
is no mention of it fact is that only
FIFA can cancel or stop the World Cup
not Russia this poster also caused April
it was shared on the web in dozens of
languages it allegedly shows rules for
the World Cup such as that alcohol and
homosexuality are forbidden in Qatar
misleading contrary to what many people
thought the poster does not come from
the Qatari government the Qatari
citizens initiative reflect your respect
which has been calling on foreigners in
particular to respect Qatari Customs
since 2014 is apparently responsible for
the poster but what about the content of
the poster itself the Supreme committee
responsible for the World Cup said it
showed factually incorrect information
so which of the bands are true let's
take a closer look with regard to
alcohol consumption the law in Qatar is
clear alcohol is not prohibited but
drinking it in public is this is
punishable by up to six months in prison
in Qatar dating however is not forbidden
under Qatari law and homosexuality that
is a punishable of fans in Qatar Qatari
law punishes it with one to five years
in prison homosexuality and the World
Cup in Qatar are topic that provides for
discussions as seen after the recent
statement by the Qatari World Cup
Ambassador and the debate of
homosexuality and the World Cup in Qatar
lead to fakes like this one here
Cristiano Ronaldo and Lionel Messi are
allegedly kissing and Qatar is calling
for the two to be banned from the World
Cup according to this Facebook post
which has been shared thousands of times
both are fake of course it is a photo
montage manned as satire with which a
youth vomit on Swiss television in 2021
wanted to draw attention to the
treatment of homosexuality in football
and qatar's demand that Messi and
Ronaldo be excluded from the World Cup
in Qatar is completely made up the same
goes for this story FIFA is said to have
excluded algeria's fans from the World
Cup as it's claimed on Facebook and
YouTube
they are not allowed to travel to Qatar
it said false
Algeria did not qualify for the World
Cup however fans from Algeria were not
excluded we could not find any such
rules or entry requirements neither from
FIFA nor from Qatar speaking of fans
this news made International headlines
Qatar is said to have bought fans
and that's right at least in a part
Qatar has invited selected International
football fans and paid for their flights
hotels accommodation and even given some
pocket money the Dutch broadcaster NOS
was the first to report on it and we
have spoken with fans who received this
offer
foreign
[Music]
oh plus we are given a per diem per day
for meals after that if we are on our
own to buy our own match tickets
we are on our own to enjoy the entire
tournament as it is that's that's
everything in a nutshell the Supreme
Committee of Qatar responsible for the
World Cup confirmed to us on request
flights hotels and accommodation costs
are paid for selected fans
nevertheless they were not bought
according to Qatar because no
consideration in the sense of promotion
was expected reports about it are
absolutely false as they say but is that
true
in our research we come across an
official paper that speaks a different
language
in the code of conduct character expects
participating fans to do exactly that
promote fans are supposed to agree to
support the Qatar World Cup by liking
and sharing social media posts using the
hashtag I am a fan and tagging the
official road to 2022 Channel
Qatar also advises participating fans
that their posts will be monitored
Qatar could require fans to delete posts
that violate the code of conduct and
disparaging the World Cup or Qatar is
not appropriate
according to our information this code
of conduct was not presented to all fans
but for the fans who were sent the
document it's fair to say that Qatar
indirectly paid them with flights hotels
tickets and pocket money in exchange for
social media reach
and in this case Qatar is said to have
paid fans as well as social media users
claim during fan marches in Qatar
thousands walked through Doha wearing
jerseys of participating Nations
according to our information most of
them are migrant workers many from India
are from India I'm working in Qatar
since
no
no I love England football
so I'm supporting England
we are from Kerala Qatar has offered
them heavily discounted tickets to World
Cup matches and it's not the first time
that Qatar has been accused of employing
Migrant workers as sports fans Qatar is
also fighting back against these
headlines International media accused
the kingdom of restricting press freedom
this is because camera teams have to
sign a list of conditions and bans that
massively restrict their work
qatar's Supreme committee contradicts
via Twitter filming is allowed after
obtaining permits and journalists can
report freely and without interference
in Qatar
false according to our research truly
free reporting from Qatar without State
interference is not possible government
buildings religious institutions
universities hospitals homes and private
business may not be firmed without
permission this is also confirmed by the
International Federation of journals ifj
these restrictions would prevent the
media from reporting on topics of public
interest such as human rights violations
we know that Doha news has been
suspended for a long time as well
for their reporting we know that the New
York Times was not able to
to disseminate some of its stories to
make his we know that the New York Times
was not able to make its stories
available on certain specific issues
such as
lgbtqr I A Plus secondly we are also
concerned about a law that exists in
Qatar which
[Music]
um
them makes any spreading of fake news or
rumors subject to very heavy fines and
up to five uh five years jail term
particularly interesting qatar's
government controls who reports when and
how about the guest workers in the
country there are poor working
conditions have been a controversial
topic for years now problem here arises
when journalists want to concentrate on
that topic of the workers and they want
to talk talk to workers they want to
indulge into their world when they are
invited into their home in the
industrial area that will not be allowed
neither now nor in the last couple of
months nowhere during the World Cup and
that might prevent a lot of journalists
to actually report on that topic on site
at all and that is then a restriction of
reporting journalists are therefore
hindered and censored in their work in
Qatar a circumstance that many observe
with great concern but there are some
bizarre rumors about the FIFA World Cup
like this fake that made us laugh here a
Facebook user claims that during this
Tournament of the World Cup a match
would last 100 minutes instead of 90.
really of course this is false a
football match lasts 90 minutes and
that's how it will stay in this world
cup as well and FIFA has also confirmed
there will be no changes in the match
length some things will be different
during this world cup but some things
will remain the same have you come
across more World Cup fakes then write
to us in the comment sections below or
to fact checking at dw.com